yeah it's casual Thursday today well you
never heard of that yes the new teaser
trailer - star trek into darkness has
hit the Internet actually I think it's a
teaser trailer for the teaser trailer
because on the website it's like hey
check back on the 17th there's gonna be
a trailer needless to say this one
minute of star trek into darkness
footage needs to be talked about why
because it has Benedict Cumberbatch in a
trailer destroying [ __ ] ever there was
something to talk about it's probably
that what I like about this trailer is
immediately it's Cumberbatch's voice you
recognize it from Sherlock if you've
seen Sherlock if you haven't seen
Sherlock why haven't you seen the BBC
series Sherlock you recognize the voice
but it's so much more menacing than you
remember you think your world is safe it
is an illusion comforting lie told to
protect you and yeah it's a total
trailer cliche to have the antagonist
doing his voiceover well shit's getting
destroyed that being said the guy has a
voice for it a shame not to use
Cumberbatch's voice in a trailer enjoy
these final moments of peace for I have
returned
to have my vengeance anything about this
no one really knows who Benedict
Cumberbatch plays there's been rumors
that he plays Khan but no one really
knows nothing is confirmed however you
look at his jacket you're like hmm
that's kind of the same pattern on
Khan's jacket kind of not really but
kind of I don't know a pattern on a
jacket isn't enough to say oh yeah
that's totally Khan doesn't change the
fact that the dude's completely gonna
kick ass but there is that scene where
he's in his Starfleet uniform sitting in
a chair so you're like oh is he on the
bridge of the enterprise is he taking
control of the enterprise because that
is a common ish type of motivations or
maybe he is calm however I got to think
anyone hell bent on vengeance and
destructions going to take the
enterprise so like I have flagship at
the Federation we'll take that one thank
you like they're gonna pass on that be
like I know we'll take the excelsior cuz
we're idiots no disrespect to the
Excelsior or Silla Oh whoever he plays
he looks like he's going to destroy
lives
and that's my favorite part of the
trailer is that scene just because of
that one chick who just screams her ass
off
she just looks completely terrified I
don't think I've seen a person in a
trailer in my life look so scared out of
their mind as that chick does right
there
yeah chick from she's out of my league
looks like she's having kind of a bad
day now one of the main complaints I've
heard about this trailer is that it just
looks like a complete action movie and
it's lost what Star Trek is all about I
don't know I can't qualify that it's
only one minute of footage so I don't
know what the movies gonna be like it
might be a complete action movie it
might have more depth to it but I don't
see this trailer is a bad thing I've
always professed teaser trailers have
one job to give you the tone of the
movie so a trailer to the teaser trailer
is gonna give you a less than that
however if this movie does with this
trailer shows it does I'm excited why
because it shows the villain in the
forefront of the entire thing the 2009
Star Trek movie if there was one gripe
about the movie is that it had a weak
villain I mean yeah the dude did some
really monumental things he sucked a
planet into itself with the black hole
that's always a bad day it's a good
villain Marc but he was still in the
background the movie was a movie about
Kirk and Spock not a bad thing I'm just
saying the villain didn't have any
weight to him this trailers like all
right you want a villain doing [ __ ] you
want him right up front here's Benedict
Cumberbatch ruining lives so shall we
begin crashing the enterprise into a
lake yeah give it please sorry Eric Bana
you may have killed Kirk's father and
ruined Spock's world but did you crash
the enterprise into a lake no at first I
was like if Cumberbatch does play Caan
that's really weird cuz I always thought
Cumberbatch was kind of built like then
lanky white dude exact opposite of calm
but after seeing him crash the
enterprise into a lake I was like it's
fine if he's caught in fact his name
could be Bob and it'd be alright he's
going to be badass so I think this looks
completely kick-ass people who were like
I looks like a mindless action movie
reserved that [ __ ] a little bit it's one
minute of footage for a two hour movie
give it a little time reserve your
judgment says the guy making a video
giving his judgement my hypocrisy only
goes so far
promised so as I said on the 17th we're
getting a new trailer for star trek into
darkness
if the trailers like 90% the same as
this I probably won't do a video about
it but if it's diff
yeah I'll throw up another video about
Star Trek so the teaser trailer to the
teaser trailer to star trek into
darkness what did you think about it and
who do you think Benedict Cumberbatch
plays you think he's Khan whatever you
think whatever your thoughts comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more